over the weekend the international
community came together and started a
sanction russia many of its citizens and
the russian central bank this is
unprecedented type action with a global
coordination of many many countries what
we see here is countries like italy and
hungary now coming together to support
russia's expulsion from the swift
banking system then we saw boris johnson
come out and say very explicitly they've
taken decisive action and they're
working with their international
partners including an important first
step of ejecting russian banks from
swift they will keep working together to
ensure putin pays for the price of his
aggression and then of course the united
states what we have here is secretary
antony blinken who said as a result of
putin's war on ukraine we join the
leaders of the eu france germany italy
uk and canada to ensure key sanctioned
russian banks are disconnected from
swift now this stuff sounds really big
really bad what you have to remember is
that the customers of those russian
banks those are actual individual
citizens people who probably actually
don't want to be in war with ukraine if
we go ahead and we take a look here what
we can see is that russia's money is not
sitting in the united states for the
most part only eight and a half percent
or so of their foreign exchange reserves
sits within the u.s or u.s banking now
china china's got 17.7 percent that's
still accessible to russia there are no
sanctions that can touch that chinese
held money but places like france japan
germany us the uk and others all
sanctioning the russian assets not
allowing them to leave their country
borders and so what is the impact of
this on the russian ruble the currency
of russia well of course it is down it
is down significantly and we're seeing
it continuing to trade down today the
russian ruble is in a free fall now
sitting at about one penny per ruble
down significantly since the start of
this invasion this is the impact of
economic sanctions this is what the
international community is doing they're
tanking the currency and they're
destroying the economy trying to apply
enough pressure to get vladimir putin to
call off the war it's important to
understand though that economic
sanctions don't actually hurt the leader
of a country instead the goal of the
sanctions is to inflict maximum pain on
the everyday citizens with the hopes
that they'll get so fed up that they'll
be in so much pain they'll rise up and
they'll either force their leaders to
make different decisions or they'll
actually remove those leaders from their
leadership position well here we see
that people in russia literally saying
my hotel asked me to settle the bill
early because they're not sure if credit
cards are going to work once the
sanctions kick in and then we've got
this photo of people lined up for hours
standing outside of atms trying to get a
sliver of their wealth back so that if
they want to leave russia or if they
simply want to buy goods and services
they aren't going to bear the brunt of
such economic sanctions ultimately
sanctions are financial censorship and
whether you agree with them or you
disagree with them it is very clear that
the international community is going to
continue to pursue these types of
activities whenever somebody steps out
of line or does something that they
disagree with and so ultimately what the
world is watching
is that a decentralized digital
censorship resistant technology is gonna
become even more important in the future